-♪ Best Friends Challenge ♪
♪ Best friends ♪
[ Laughter ]
-I know.
Uh, all right, the game works
like the newly wed game,
but for friends.
And I've played this
with Tina Fey,
I've played this with Justin.
And I am not friends
with either of them. [ Laughs ]
So I don't know
if the game works
but we're gonna take turns
reading questions
about each other from
the Best Friends Box, okay?
-I love that
I'm in their company.
-Yeah, of course you are.
-Thank you.
-Well, we're gonna try to write
down the same answer.
We didn't plan any of this out,
we really didn't.
-No we don't know
the questions at all.
-I don't think
the game would be fun if I did.
-That's what I always tell my
kids, it's no fun if you cheat.
-That's right.
All right good.
I will read the first question,
are you ready for this?
-Yeah.
And we'll both write down
what I think the answer is.
-Okay.
-If Jimmy was a Spice Girl...
-Yes! Whoo!
-...which one would he be?
-Oh, God.
[ Light laughter ]
♪♪
-All right.
Drew, if I was a Spice Girl,
which on would I be?
What did you write?
[ Light laughter ]
-Sporty?
[ Laughter ]
I'm so Scary.
Are you kidding me?
[ Laughter ]
Kidding me, man?
Mel B. all the way, man.
-Oh, okay.
-Sporty?
-Well, it's a really kind of
hard question because --
-But I would never even --
-Like "Sex and the City,"
each woman represents a
characteristic of our womanhood.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
-Are you a baby, are you tough,
are you scary?
Like, it's, you know.
-You are such a Samantha right
now I can't even talk about it.
-By the way,
you don't even know.
-[ Laughs ] All right read
the nex-- the next question.
-Okay.
-Sporty. Yeah.
Oh, my God.
You're in so much trouble.
But she was.
Also I was trying to --
-So much trouble.
-I was trying to picture you
in all the costumes
and the one that sort of
seemed the most appropriate --
I did!
I saw you in like --
-Camo pants!
-Ginger, she always had
the bustier and then --
-Nah, don't picture me in that.
Okay here we go.
-Exactly.
So I was like Sporty.
If Drew could adopt
any exotic animal as a pet,
what would it be?
[ Laughs ]
[ Light laughter ]
-Any exotic animal as a pet.
Oh, man.
Gosh you know right off the bat
what it would be.
An exotic.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughing ] Okay.
[ Laughs ] All right time's up.
Put your [Laughs] pencils down.
[ Laughs ]
-[ Drew laughs ]
-What is your answer?
Ooh, yeah.
-Its a monkey.
And it's saying --
-Is that your monkey?
-It's it's saying "Che che"
-[ Jimmy laughs ]
-Of course monkey.
I just put elephant
and I drew an elephant too.
-Right there. [ Laughs ]
See that's what
makes us besties is we know --
-We drew the animals.
-Yeah. exactly.
We didn't know we were gonna
draw the animals.
-No.
I think that's at least
a half a point.
-Monkey's pretty cool.
Yeah that's something.
-All right here we go, ready?
-Okay your turn.
-All right.
If we opened a restaurant,
what would we call it?
-[ Both gasp, laugh ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-All right, Drew,
what did you write? [ Laughs ]
What did you write?
-Jimmy & Drew's.
-Yeah.
-And our thing would be "Eey."
[ Laughter ]
-No, Bil's and Sil's of course.
-Oh, no! God!
Bil's and Sil's!
All right we'll do one more,
it's your turn to read.
-Oh, okay.
-Uh-huh.
-[ Clears throat ] If we had --
-Eey.
-Eey. Jimmy & Drew's.
There'd be no other word
than "Eey".
You order, "Eey."
Come in, "Eey."
-Eey.
You get the check,
you're like "Eey!"
[ Laughter ]
All right, pal, here we go.
This is for the win.
This is worth 1,000 points.
[ Laughter ]
-If we had a theme song,
what would it be?
-Oh, my God.
-Well, like, is it one that
exists, are we making it up?
-All right, probably one that
exists, if we had a theme song.
-Okay, okay.
Okay. I got it.
-Oh, no!
Oh, I'm forgetting it.
All right, hold on a second.
I need one second of just
complete silence.
[ Light laughter ]
And zen, let me focus on this.
-Ooh, Sharpie.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't sniff the Sharpie!
[ Groans ]
-[ Laughs ] I love that you've
given up on your own answer.
[ Laughter ]
-All right. I'm just gonna tell
you mine because it's not right.
-Jesus, oh, shoe.
-Sharpie.
Oh, Sharpie.
-[ Laughs ]
-It's just
one of those moments
at someone's house
where like I'm just gonna
act casual
and then go grab it.
-You just wrecked the carpet.
Now are you ready here we go.
I put and this is wrong,
I put Happy Days theme song.
We've never even sung it,
but we do.
-Okay. Okay. We're okay.
-We're okay because?
-I'll tell you why, we were on
together, "Lavern and Shirley."
-What?!
-Yes! See!
-Schlemiel!
-Schlimazel!
-Hasenpfeffer Incorporated!
-I love her! Drew yes!
We got a point for that.
Garry Marshall [ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪